So Bernie Sanders is either taking a call
it like I see it approach with Donald Trump's
ADC, or he simply gotten pushed over the point
at which he's sick and tired of the idiocy
of this administration, but he is now being
targeted because he was so mean to Trump on
Twitter.
And so unpresidential because he said Donald
Trump's belief or at least statement that
climate change is a hoax, makes him an idiot.
That that's quite simply what he tweeted over
the weekend.
Quote, Donald Trump believes climate change
is a hoax.
Donald Trump is an idiot.
Oh, know what a mean.
Unpresidential immature thing to say about
stop the concern trolling.
Okay, the you these concern trolls have no
leg to stand on.
You should pay no attention to them.
Remember that as this was happening, Donald
Trump was tweeting basement dwelling conspiracy
theories about Jeffrey Epstein and the Clintons.
He was having a two month old orphaned baby,
brought back to a hospital for a sick photo
op with him and Melania.
If the argument is that Bernie is unpresidential
in this tweet, what about Donald Trump's years
of attacking people and ideas?
And the truth on Twitter endlessly in a completely
irrational and unpresidential way.
You have no leg to stand on.
Trumpists don't really care about unpresidential
on Twitter because if they did, they'd never
voted for Donald Trump in the first place,
or at minimum would have stopped supporting
Trump by now.
Bernie is right.
Trump is an idiot, but I actually don't believe
Trump thinks climate change is a hoax.
In reality, Trump thinks that dealing with
climate change, accepting it, accepting that
humans are impacting it, making policy as
a result of that acceptance would be bad for
him and for the businesses of his friends,
period.
In the meantime, Trump insists it's a hoax
and it does convince a lot of people that
it is straight up a hoax.
People who have nothing to gain, by the way,
from pretending that it's a hoax like Trump
and his friends do, but I actually believe
Trump knows climate change is not a hoax.
I don't think he really understands the specifics
of it.
He doesn't seem to read anything.
He doesn't seem to listen in depth to any
issue, but I think that this is for his own
game, that he asserts that it is a hoax and
people get convinced by it and the concerted
effort to suppress information about climate
change and climate science is too much for
just believing that it's a hoax.
It's what you need to do when you know it's
not a hoax, but you've got to pretend it is
by covering up all of the serious information
about it, which they've been doing within
the USDA.
They've been doing it within NASA, they've
been doing it elsewhere, and I want to sort
of flip this around.
Anyone who's not taking climate change seriously
as a matter of policy must be ridiculed.
It would be immoral not to ridicule Donald
Trump, whatever his sincerely held belief
is about the climate change issue for even
propagating the idea that it is a hoax.
He needs to be ridiculed.
It is a moral every single day.
We're falling further behind and actually
dealing with the climate crisis every day.
Trump is doing the opposite of what should
be done.
Not Publishing research from his own administration,
but rather suppressing it, not strengthening
standards on vehicle efficiency and more,
but rather weakening them.
And this is actually super straightforward.
It's not the language we might've expected
in politics 10 years ago.
Donald Trump is an idiot from a 70 something
year old senator, but this is the Trump era.
This is not a theoretical discussion about
whether or not Bernie should or shouldn't
be using this language.
The content of Bernie's tweet is effectively
accurate.
If the argument is it's not presidential language,
go talk to Trump about his language because
he uses that language all the time.
But if you are focused on the language, you're
ignoring that Bernie Sanders is right about
the critical reality of dealing with the climate
right now.
Trump is not doing it.
And I say good for Bernie and people, you
know, people call in and say, David, do you
think that the Trump presidency, even after
he's gone is going to maintain an effect?
And the answer is yes.
Donald Trump's presidency, even after he's
gone, we'll open up the door to more Trump
like ignoramuses to be elected to office,
state, local, national, wherever, because
they are seen as legitimate, uh, voices, uh,
in the political discussion, which they should
not be.
They should be laughed at.
Again, as I said, if Donald Trump wasn't given
a small loan of $1 million to start a business,
his rantings would be the thing you would
expect to see from the guy who just urinated
on the subway tracks, uh, before going back
underneath the stairs while yelling at everybody
who's down there.
But he's in a different position because of
a financial thing.
Uh, so that, that has been legitimized, that
idea, these types of people who have been
legitimized as politicians with valid voices,
uh, by the Trump administration.
Not that everyone shouldn't be heard, but
just because someone should have the right
to vote doesn't mean that they should be president
of the United States.
We're talking about two different things and
the coarsening of the language.
Quite frankly, I don't think there is any
putting the genie back in the bottle or putting
the toothpaste back in the tube so to speak,
with the sort of discourse that has become
legitimized over the last few years.
And it's not just going to be Republicans
who, who sort of take to that discourse.
So what I say is on the subject matter, on
the merits, good for Bernie and the criticisms
about it being the wrong language.
Well go and talk to Trump about the wrong
language.